so today's draft chris sims most
impressive single game performance in
nfl history you've got a trivia question
for me that will determine the first
pick in the draft yep okay here we go
jameis winston okay led the nfl in
passing yards last year at the age of
25.
in the last 10 years only one other
quarterback led the nfl in passing yards
before turning 30 which i found very
interesting who was it
led the nfl in passing yards you want to
hit returning 30. give me a hint
well he's still playing
he's not he's not currently on a team
right now
oh colin kaepernick
[Music]
ah
you baited me phillips rivers
oh he's not well that's good well he is
currently on the team he's still
property the chargers that is a false
hint he's still on the chargers he's
still on the charges he's not a free
agent till march 18. you gave me a
faulty hint sims you can take the first
page is he or is he not in the pft top
100 free agents right now he's due to
become a free agent on march 18th hey
lawyers shut up lawyer they didn't
release him go puke puking at trash cans
okay i might do that fine okay don't
corner me i might do it all right all
right here we go i got so many damn
options for this thing right now i don't
know where to begin but my first pick is
this
gale sayers
versus the san francisco 49ers 1965.
okay we're talking about wilt
chamberlain 100 points in a game amazing
unbelievable how about touching the ball
14 times and having 336 total yards and
six touchdowns yeah the kansas comet
gale sayers with the punt returns
everything like that in a route where
they won 61 to 20 against the san
francisco 49ers to me that goes down as
one of the greatest performances ever in
a single game in the history of the nfl
first off his highlights are off the
charts i mean it's just amazing he is
truly like a human highlight but that's
amazing to touch the ball 14 times and
have 336 total yards and six touchdowns
you talk about maxing out your your
carries or touches of the ball that's
about as good as i've ever seen
and it's a damn shame that medical
technology wasn't at the point then that
it is now because it was a knee injury
that cut his career short he still made
it to the hall of fame and i think that
game had a lot to do with it not that he
was otherwise bad but that game stands
out and it echoes 50 plus years later if
he could have gotten over that knee
injury and continue to play my goodness
what he could have become he was still
special hall of famer for the chicago
bears but uh yeah i that's a great
selection by you right out of the gates
and i'm going to go back even farther
into the history books i was at least
alive for that one although i was less
than a year old
in 19 and
51
norm van brocklin with a and i used to
be very impressed by the johnny unitas
record for consecutive games with a
touchdown pass because he did it back in
an era where passing was not anything
like it is now in 1951 norm van brocklin
threw for
554 yards in a game and it's never been
broken through all the rule changes and
all of the high-flying offenses and all
the focus on pass the ball pass the ball
pass the ball nobody has thrown for 550
more or more since 1951 when norm van
brocklin did it and great job by the
control room i don't know that this is
the exact game if it is even more
impressive
554 yards in one game i don't know what
kind of defense they were playing in a
day of run the ball run the ball to have
that much
passing yardage but 554 that's mine that
would have been my first pick if i'd won
the draft so either way i'm satisfied
yeah that's good i hear you he was on my
list too and i mean that is amazing 554
i mean in that era i mean that's like
throwing for 700 yards in a game now i
mean that's that's really what it is and
that's that's what's amazing about it uh
and you know norm van brock on another
guy that probably gets lost in the
shuffle because he played such a long
long time ago where yeah he's one of the
greats our sport's ever seen and we
don't really talk about them a whole lot
right so uh i i hear you there all right
man i'm in a tough spot here i got so
many damn names
hey you know what else
brooklyn was the original coach in the
minnesota vikings wow i did not i did
not know that i did not um i think i got
to go with joe montana and super bowl 24
for my next one i mean joe montana super
bowl 24 not only was the nfl mvp that
year the super bowl mvp sports
illustrated man of the year or sportsman
of the year which used to be a big deal
but that to me will always stand out as
one of the greatest super performances i
ever saw i mean hey you win your fourth
super bowl you get the mvp you throw for
five touchdown passes
he broke my dad's record of 13 straight
completions in the game uh during that
run i mean that was surgical i can just
remember sitting there watching that
game as a young boy just going oh my
gosh the denver broncos have no chance
john montana every pass is touched down
and you know black 56 laser black 56
laser right you ever see that all at nfl
things like that was that game to me
that will always stand out to being one
of the best quarterback performances i
have ever seen and of course it was on
the super bowl stage which magnifies it
even more
and i vividly recall
that game because it was a year after
the
bengals 49ers down to the wire and we're
starting to think maybe super bowls are
changing now they're not gonna blow out
so i remember we kind of settled in we
had all the food and we're ready to go
this is gonna be a great game and it was
snooze fest uh unless you're a 49ers fan
so that's a good selection by you but
not a historic day i am going to go with
another guy who did something as a
rookie that for him is a record that
still stands as to anyone who's ever
played the game and that's adrian
peterson against the then san diego
chargers 2007 at the old metrodome
rushing for a single game record of 296
yards man very impressive by the control
room those they're on fire that's
vikings uniform
but uh yeah 296 yards a guy who was a
rookie at the time that's not the year
he almost set the single season rushing
record but 296 he had some injuries as a
rookie missed some time but uh no no
time missed that day he was unstoppable
against the charter yeah i mean i still
can remember it i mean i just remember
going like oh my gosh this guy i mean
he's from another planet you know you've
heard me talk about stories about him
you know i i've seen a lot of great
running backs in my life and in person
and hey the one he was playing against
that day ladainian thompson will still
be one of the guys that always sticks
out in my brain i can remember in 2004
watching ladainian thomason on the
sidelines when i was playing for the
bucks and just going whoa this is
amazing look how good he is and yet as
good as that was it wasn't what i saw
from adrian peterson in person in 2008
when i saw him i was blown away and i've
i've never seen anybody move the way he
did and that was an amazing game an
amazing performance all right i'm going
i got some more trivia for you i got
some more trivia for you in that same
game just before the half ryan longwell
attempted a 57-yard field goal antonio
cromartie caught it at the back of the
end zone oh and returned it 109 yards
for a touchdown that was like the first
that was when that started to happen
you're right that was really the first
of its kind right i mean i want to say
it was it was him or maybe my buddy
nathan vasher the chicago bears they
started doing that and uh yeah that's
right i remember that that was a fun
game to watch holy cow gosh i have so
many options here again you know i want
to pick my dad in super bowl 21 but
whatever that's not cool i mean yeah i
know that's my favorite dominating
performance but i'm not gonna pick them
all right i'm gonna go you're just gonna
mention it for three minutes i'm gonna
give them a little shout out okay i
usually say screws phil sims this one
i'll show him a little love all right
willie flipper flipper anderson flipper
anderson 1989
that rams team with jim everett at
quarterback they're playing the new
orleans saints i can still remember
watching this game it was like every
ball was going to flipper but flipper
336 yards receiving in a game
15 receptions i mean that's that's
insane
336 yards receiving i don't know what
how many yards did jim ever throw for in
the game i don't know i don't really
care but flipper anderson another you
know one of those guys that's like an
nfl legend we don't talk about a whole
lot but i had some experience with him
in this year i mean this year he beat my
dad's giants team twice i remember
watching this game and of course later
in this year in the playoffs he caught
the overtime touchdown and ran out the
tunnel in giant stadium which made me
cry so flipper anderson that performance
is about as good as i can ever remember
4 54 for jim everett that day wow that's
that's amazing only a hundred and only a
hundred and eighteen yards to everybody
else on the team that's unreal
that was quick math by you i don't know
whether it's correct or not there's a
chance it's not all right last one for
me
uh and and this let's go defense we
haven't gone defense yet derek thomas
1990 against the seattle seahawks seven
sacks in one game still the single game
record he was dominant he was
unstoppable except on the last play of
the game and tony dungey who was
defensive coordinator to the chiefs at
the time tells this story of how on the
last play of the game derek thomas had
dave craig lined up for sack number
eight right and craig wiggled away and
threw the game-winning touchdown pass to
paul scancy remember paul scans i do the
only ones who do i do i do and i
remember i mean i remember that and yes
i mean i wish we had the highlight but
you're right he's got dave craig in his
hands for the nine sack and he slips out
and throws the touchdown it's
unbelievable but that that yes that will
be uh that will be one i will never
forget about the late great derek thomas
legend
you know there are others that that i
had on the list uh
you know terrell owens had 20 catches in
a game once yeah unbelievable back in
december of 2000. and i didn't realize
jerry rice had a five touchdown game in
1990. five touchdowns i mean that's
right that's just that's a click below
gail sayers i always thought early in
randy moss's career he was going to have
a game like that i thought it was just a
matter of time before he had like a six
touchdown game right never happened
obviously but i really felt like it was
going to be him and remember when reggie
bush came in yeah his birthday was
yesterday too happy birthday reggie
there was that sense he was going to be
the new gail sayers and there was going
to be a moment like that for him and
obviously it never happened but we we
keep waiting for that guy to have that
dominant performance like gayle sayers
and i think you know back to to your
first selection i think that makes it
even more appropriate because that is
like the first i i was messing with you
about norm van brocklin the gail sayers
game from 1965 is still all these years
later the first one that comes to mind
when you just think of sheer dominance
and per touch right impact on a game
right it was like it was like a a man
playing with kids that's what it looks
like i mean what's amazing is some of
those plays you watch like he's not down
in a two-hand touch football game nobody
can get two hands on him he gets just
like one hand touches and people just
grasping for him as he goes by
uh that's one of those guys where you
always will wonder like a bo jackson
where you just go man if they stayed
healthy what would their have career
really ended up looking like what kind
of numbers and stats could they have put
up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports